>> Greg: DOJ SECURITY FEARS
WERE OVER TRUMP'S SOUVENIRS.
THEY SAID IT WAS THE ULTIMATE
CRIME TO KEEP UP FRAMED COVER OF
TIME.
THE LATEST BOMBSHELLS TO COME
FROM THE MAR-A-LAGO DOCUMENTS
REVEALED DONALD TRUMP'S WITHOUT
A SHADOW OF A DOUBT
DONALD TRUMP.
THE DOJ FILING RELEASED ON
TUESDAY INCLUDED A PHOTO OF
DOCUMENTS SEIZED AND IT TURNS
OUT TRUMP HAD A FRAMED "TIME"
MAGAZINE COVER OF HIMSELF.
IF THAT'S ILLEGAL, SOMEONE
BETTER RATE HAROLD FORD'S
BASEMENT.
WHAT YOU THINK HAROLD HASN'T
FRAMED A COPY OF THIS FOR HIS
HOME?
I KNOW I DID.
I HAVE SEVERAL OF THEM ABOVE MY
BED AND ONE IN THE BATHROOM.
ANYWAY.
GET THAT BACK THERE.
THAT TIME COVER WAS FROM A 2019
ISSUE DETAILING THE DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARY RACE WITH ALL THE
CHALLENGES LOOKING OUT TRUMP.
LET'S TAKE A MOMENT TO BE GLAD
THAT WASN'T A SWIMSUIT ISSUE.
TRUMP FRAMING THE ISSUE AND
KEEPING IT IS WHAT ANY OF US
WOULD DO, YET THE MEDIA CALLS IT
A STUNNING DETAIL.
JESUS.
IN OTHER WORDS WE ARE BACK TO
WHERE WE'VE ALWAYS BEEN, THE
SAME SILLY, HILARIOUS STUFF THAT
FEEDS THE MEDIA'S TRUMP
OBSESSION.
THEY ARE MORE OBSESSED WITH HIM
THEN STORMY DANIELS EVER WAS.
THE OTHER BOMBSHELL THIS WEEK,
TRUMP LOVES TO GOSSIP.
APPARENTLY HE BRAGGED HE KNEW
ILLICIT DETAILS THE FRENCH
PRESIDENT EMMANUEL MACRON'S LOVE
LIFE AND THAT CAME FROM
INTELLIGENCE HE HAD BEEN BRIEFED
ON.
WHO WOULDN'T GOSSIP ABOUT THAT?
MACRON'S WIFE WAS HIS OLD
HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER WHO IS 25
YEARS OLDER THAN HIM.
I GUESS SHE WASN'T JUST BANGING
THE ERASERS.
TRACE, YOU'VE BEEN COVERING THE
GRADE.
MUCH OF THE MEDIA FOCUS ON?
>> Trace: I'M CONFUSED.
ARE THEY LOOKING FOR SECRET
DOCUMENTS OR SACRED DOCUMENTS?
EVERY TIME TRUMP IS ON THE COVER
OF A MAGAZINE, YOU KNOW TO HIM,
THAT'S A SACRED DOCUMENT.
YOU LOOK AT ALL THOSE FOLDERS
AND YOU THINK, ARE THEY ALL
FILLED WITH MAGAZINE COVERS?
THAT'S WHAT IT COULD BE.
REMEMBER WHEN TRUMP WAS ACCUSED
OF PUTTING UP PHONY "TIME"
MAGAZINE PICTURES IN ALL OF HIS
GOLF CLUBS AROUND THE COUNTRY.
IT WAS KIND OF BIG JOKE.
THE TRUTH IS IT'S COME DOWN TO
THIS BIZARRE THING.
TWO WEEKS AGO
"THE WASHINGTON POST" REPORTS
THAT WHAT IS IN THE SECRET
DOCUMENTS OR NUCLEAR SECRETS.
THESE ARE NUCLEAR THINGS.
THEY HAVE PULLED AWAY FROM THAT
NOW IT SEEMS TO BE A BATTLE OVER
DOCUMENTS THAT TRUMP JUST WON'T
GIVE BACK.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S IN THERE.
HE WON'T GIVE THEM BACK IN THE
DOJ IS PISSED ABOUT IT.
>> Greg: SOME MOVER PACKER
THROUGH ALL THE CRAP INTO A BOX
AND MIX EVERYTHING UP, UP AND
THAT'S WHAT I WOULD DO.
TRUMP IS LIKE WHATEVER, I'LL GET
TO IT WHEN I GET TO IT.
HE PROBABLY THINKS THIS IS SUCH
A BORING CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
DOCUMENTS.
I DON'T REALLY CARE.
>> I WAS LOOKING AT THIS PICTURE
AND I WAS ZOOMING IN AND TRYING
TO REALLY STUDY IT.
THE ONE THING I NOTICED IS THAT
ALL THOSE TOP-SECRET THINGS,
THEY ARE PAPER CLIP DOG.
YOU SEE THE PAPER CLIPS.
THEY ARE NOT STABLE.
I WOULD THINK STAPLING WOULD BE
SO MUCH MORE EFFICIENT.
IF YOU PAPER CLIP IT, IT COULD
COME UP.
THE TOP-SECRET COVER PAGES, YOU
CAN ORDER THEM FROM THE GENERAL
SERVICES AND ADMINISTRATION.
BE THEY JUST ORDERED A BUNCH
TOOK PAPER CLIPS AND PUT THEM ON
STUFF.
I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS A
BOMBSHELL OR NOT.
BUT YEAH, ALL THE STUFF ABOUT
THE CARPET IN THE "TIME"
MAGAZINE COVERS.
>> Greg: IT'S TRUE.
TO TRACE'S POINT, IT WENT FROM
NUCLEAR CODE SECRETS TO
"STUNNING DETAIL."
"TIME" MAGAZINE COVER.
I WANT TO SHOW EVERYBODY THAT I
WAS ON A COVER ONCE.
ANCHORAGE DAILY.
TAKE THAT, HAROLD.
YOU WERE NEVER ON ANCHORS
MAGAZINE.
>> Harold: I GAVE THAT TO YOU.
>> Greg: I KNOW YOU DID, AMONG
MANY OTHER THINGS.
HE'S A VERY GENEROUS PERSON.
WHAT'S WRONG WITH YOU, JANIE?
IT WOULD BE INTERESTING IF
SOMEBODY HAD INTEL, AND INTEL
FILE ON YOUR SEX LIFE.
IT WOULD PROBABLY BE A BLANK
PAGE.
SINCE YOUR DIVORCE.
>> Jamie: IT PROBABLY WOULD BE
BLANK.
WASN'T THERE ONE, WASN'T THERE
ONE OF THE "TIME" MAGAZINE
COVERS THAT HE SAVED.
I RESPECTED THIS TRADE WASN'T
FOR THEY SAID NEGATIVE STUFF AND
HE SAVED IT.
IT'S SUPER COOL.
I GET MOTIVATED BY THINGS THAT
WERE A FAILURE.
AND MY MARRIAGE CERTIFICATE IN
MY OFFICE.
I AM HAVING A NAME BLANK.
MARK COHEN.
MACRO?
TRUMP SAYING THAT HE HAS INSIDE
INFORMATION ON MACRON'S SEX
LIFE.
IT'S PRETTY COOL HE WAS ON
"TIME" MAGAZINE.
NEXT MONTH BIDEN IS GOING TO BE
ON "TIMES UP" MAGAZINE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: RED MEAT, HAROLD.
HE JUST THREW A BIG SLAB OF RED
MEAT AT YOU.
>> Harold: HE COULD BE ON THE
COVER OF THOSE MAGAZINE SAYING
THAT HE WON.
YOU HAVE TO GET BACK.
ELECTIONS ARE WON IF YOU PUT
FORTH GREAT IDEAS.
ON THIS TRUMP THING FOR ONE
MOMENT.
IF I PACKED UP AND SOMEONE TOLD
ME TO PACK MY THINGS UP AND THEY
PACK THEM UP FOR ME AND I
REALIZED I HAD SOMETHING.
THE DOCUMENTS ARE NOT HIS.
WHEN YOU'RE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND WE WILL SAY
SHE ONE DAY BUT HE IS THE
CUSTODIAN.
>> Greg: A SEXIST MIGHT SAY.
>> Harold: YOU ARE THE
CUSTODIAN OF THOSE PAPERS, NOT
THE OWNER.
WHEN YOU LEAVE OFFICE YOU DO GET
ACCESS TO THEM FOR THE PURPOSES
OF WRITING A BOOK AND OTHER
THINGS.
IF YOU DIDN'T KNOW WHAT WAS IN
THE BOX.
SANCTUS, THERE ARE THINGS IN THE
BOX.
IT I WOULD RETURN THEM.
>> Greg: HE'S TOO BUSY.
IT WOULD BE COOL IF THEY OPENED
THE BOX WITH GWYNETH PALTROW'S
HEAD.
>> Harold: I'M GOING TO LEAVE
IT ALONE BUT THEY ASKED MULTIPLE
TIMES AND HE DIDN'T TURN THEM
OVER.
>> Trace: THE ONLY EQUATION WE
HAVE.
HILLARY CLINTON.
SHE WAS NEVER PRESIDENT BUT SHE
HAD CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS AND SHE
WAS STILL A PUBLIC OFFICIAL.
THEY ARE SAYING THAT THE
PRESIDENTIAL THING IS OUT OF IT
BECAUSE HE'S OUT OF OFFICE.
NOW THEY ARE SAYING
HILLARY CLINTON HAD CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS SO IF YOU'RE GOING TO
DEAL EQUALLY.
I'M A BIG DUE PROCESS GUIDE.
IF YOU ARE GOING TO GIVE DUE
PROCESS, YOU SHOULD HAVE EQUAL
TREATMENT.
THE DOJ SHOULD'VE AT LEAST
GOTTEN AN OPINION FROM THE DOJ
LAWYERS.